bitcoin has been one of the best
performing assets over the last decade
and there are many many people across
finance and asset allocation that are
looking for ways to get exposure but
because of their investment mandate they
may not actually be able to just go buy
bitcoin or get exposure via the current
means this has put a lot of eyes on the
idea of a spot bitcoin etf now there are
a number of countries around the world
that have gone ahead and approved that
bitcoin spot etf but in the united
states we still don't have one we simply
got the approval of a bitcoin futures
etf it's a step in the right direction
but it doesn't exactly solve the problem
for most investors who are looking to
gain exposure to the digital currency
now we get news that it looks like
australia is going to go ahead and
approve a brand new bitcoin spot etf now
this spot etf is a little unique in that
it won't actually invest in bitcoin
directly but rather in shares of the
purpose investments bitcoin etf which
was north america's first bitcoin spot
etf that began trading in early 2021. if
we look here we've got the bloomberg
analyst that spent all day thinking
about etfs and eric said that australia
is the eighth country to approve a spot
bitcoin etf the cosmos bitcoin etf will
list on april 27th and they're expected
to bring in a billion dollars right off
the bat that's the equivalent of a
hundred billion dollars in the united
states so this begs the question where
exactly are we with the bitcoin spot etf
in the united states everyone is
watching the multi-billion dollar
grayscale bitcoin trust is already
trading in the public markets will they
be able to convert to an etf will the
sec give them a green light well if we
take a look at that situation we know
that grayscale's bitcoin trust is the
largest bitcoin fund in the world
they've been one of the loudest industry
voices for getting the spot etf approved
but it's not just the ceo making the
push either thousands of their investors
have now sent letters to the sec showing
frustration over the commission's
rejection of that spot etf product
shares of the fund have been trading at
a massive discount for months and that
is inspiring an attempt to transition it
into that etf product where redemptions
would finally be possible grayscale's
currently in a waiting pattern the sec
is set to make a decision in july now i
don't know exactly what's going to
happen and something tells me that the
sec isn't really that excited about
approving the bitcoin spot etf yet but
grayscale's got a pretty good case it
appears the ceo of grayscale michael
made a great point where he stated that
if the sec can't look at two like issues
the futures etf and the spot etf through
the same lens then it is in fact
potentially grounds for an
administrative procedure act violation
this is going to be one of the most
important things to pay attention to at
the intersection of bitcoin and legacy
finance if a bitcoin spot etf gets
approved in the united states the
thought process is that billions
potentially tens of billions and maybe
even a hundred billion dollars will flow
into that product very very quickly we
saw with the gold etf that when it got
approved gold's price went up
significantly in a short period of time
the idea here is that if all of a sudden
many of these large pools of capital
these professional sophisticated asset
allocators are finally able to get
exposure to bitcoin if a finite supply
of an asset and a drastic increase in
demand
the us dollar price would have to
accelerate to accommodate everyone hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time